[Music]
on this wednesday night protecting a
woman's right to choose the
traditionally conservative state of
kansas keeps abortion legal i hope we
inspire other states what this could
signal for the midterm elections this
fall dealing with delays at canada's
busiest airport these e-gates
should make a significant difference
what could calm the turbulence
food insecurity and inflation up north
new relief for a region hungry for a
solution plus two lives well lived
remembering canadian civil rights
champion clayton ruby and baseball
broadcasting behemoth vin scully it's
time for dodger baseball
[Applause]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight bara nasser
good evening thank you for joining us at
a time when abortion access is under
assault in the united states residents
in one of the most conservative states
have voted overwhelmingly to uphold a
woman's right to choose in the first
referendum on the issue since the end of
roe versus wade voters came out in
droves and sent a strong message that
they will not give up their rights
jackson prosco reports on how that has
upended america's political landscape
less than 100 days before the crucial
midterm elections
the message was undeniable
as voters in kansas overwhelmingly
rejected plans to eliminate the state's
constitutional protections for abortion
i'm super proud to be from kansas
tonight and i feel like my state just
showed up and boldly told me that they
are going to take care of me and my
female friends even in the most rural
deeply conservative areas anti-abortion
support was far lower than expected
the first test of voters in the post row
era showed moves by the supreme court
and republican lawmakers are deeply
unpopular the vote actually really
mirrored where americans are on abortion
nationwide a majority of americans think
there should be some
aspects of abortion that should be legal
it all suggests that abortion access
could be the defining issue in
november's midterm elections democrats
feared losing control of congress
suddenly they see a path to keeping even
expanding their majority by painting
anti-abortion republicans and the
supreme court as too extreme court
practically dared women in this country
to go to the ballot box and restore the
right to choose
at the white house president joe biden
signed an executive order extending
legal protection to women who have to
travel for abortion services restoring
abortion access everywhere requires an
act of congress democrats need to elect
at least two more senators to make that
happen
back in kansas signs the once
unthinkable may now be possible after
voters in one of the most conservative
states drew a line in the sand
if you can see that the no votes win
here then that would mean that you could
have that in any part of the country no
matter how red it is
already there are signs republicans have
started to worry about the tide turning
against them several republican
governors who initially praised the
overturn of roe v wade are now starting
to back away from plans for outright
abortion bans in their own states
farah
jackson prescott washington thank you
jackson here at home the third and final
official conservative leaders debate
tonight looked different
two of the five candidates including the
apparent front runner chose to sit this
one out the big question is will the
event have any impact on the outcome of
the race abigail beamon reports
people can't get a passport in this
country because again the liberals just
can't get the job done a calm and
friendly debate with most barbs aimed at
the current government rather than
candidates sparring who would have
thought we'd be a country that you can
visit for a week and leave your butt
luggage here for two weeks jean cheray
also targeted the man who wasn't there
more than once
for a candidate in a leadership race not
to participate in the debate it's like a
fish who says he doesn't want to swim in
the ocean paulie evan leslie lewis
backed out risking a 50 thousand dollar
fine i think the vast majority of
members just aren't going to
really make time on what hopefully
across the country is a lovely summer
evening polyeff's camp blamed the debate
timing being in the middle of the get
out the vote period and slammed the last
debate as an embarrassment i think it
should happen and yes please
lewis blamed a lack of details she
wanted questions on topics such as the
world economic forum and abortion
experts believe most party members have
already decided who to vote for and that
the debate could be more helpful to pick
a second or third choice none of them is
in this to try to get your down ballot
support at this point they're all
looking to try to prevent apolly a
victory on the first ballot topics
included climate change i love trees i
love canadian forest
let's try to capture most of our
emissions naturally transportation and
leadership we need to end supply
management while roman babber focused on
covid regulations it would still force
15 percent of canadians to detain
themselves under threat of jail every
time they enter and exit canada a new
leader will be chosen september 10th and
a record-breaking
679 thousand members will be able to
cast a ballot that's more than double
the membership as when the last leader
aaron o'toole was elected back in 2020
abigail beeman global news ottawa ottawa
police say one person's in custody after
a vehicle was rammed into the front
gates of parliament hill early this
morning
the area outside the legislature was
cordoned off today but no major damage
was immediately visible police say it
happened about 3 30 this morning a
nearby officer took the driver into
custody charges are pending and there's
no word yet on a motive behind the
incident
and in a separate incident not far away
at the prime minister's official
residence cleanup is underway after a
tour bus crashed into the security fence
the bus was on a daily test drive when
it ran into the fence at 24 sussex drive
no passengers were on board and no one
was injured the residence has been
vacant since 2015 undergoing extensive
renovations
it has been a summer travel season full
of staffing shortages lost luggage and
flight delays and cancellations
toronto's pearson international though
may have found a way to alleviate some
of the airport chaos as it unveiled a
new modernized e-gate system it's a
welcome announcement for some but as
shawn o'shea reports many travelers say
it's too little too late
at canada's busiest airport the summer
of 2022 is one travelers will long
remember but may wish to forget it was a
hectic time it was a hectic time toronto
pearson was recently ranked worst in the
world for flight delays among the top
100 airports globally
add in luggage that doesn't arrive for
days and long lineups leaving canada and
coming home certainly was a challenging
start to the summer for travelers and we
certainly
you know
wish that wasn't the case and have
worked very hard with our partners to
make that better now the airport
promises more efficiency it's just
installed e-gates like these at terminal
one for arriving international
passengers more machines is more
self-service processing a dozen have
gone in allowing passengers to show
travel documents get photographed and
move more quickly they'll still need to
speak to a border agent if only briefly
we're seeing processes of about 40
seconds on an e-gate particularly with
someone who's done an advanced
declaration i think these e-gates should
make a significant difference in delays
at the airports and only speed things up
what took so long travelers say they
need to be more proactive and they
should have done their homework past
couple months
it's been horrible
something needs to change definitely the
gates will be added to terminal 3 in the
next year and other canadian airports at
some point
as for having enough border agents
something that had been an issue earlier
the cbsa says it's got enough staff now
we're staffing based on the arrivals
that we're expecting we are hopefully
past the nightmare days of the three to
five hour waits to get off planes and
through the terminal the e-gates may
provide some relief and the airport
claims that lineups for outbound
security have also diminished but
authorities warn people should still
arrive early and be patient shawn o'shea
global news toronto
after exploding in size over the past
few days the karemius wildfire in bc's
interior is holding steady tonight to
nearly 2 800 hectares crews have made
progress dousing the flames thanks to
cooler weather and more firefighters on
the front lines more than 300 properties
are under an evacuation order while
nearly 500 are under an evacuation alert
in northern california at least four
people are dead from the state's largest
wildfire of the year after two more
bodies were found within the mckinney
fire's perimeter the blaze has grown
around 230 square kilometers forcing
thousands to flee their homes it
recently wiped out a small town that was
home to 200 people and it's still out of
control while incoming rain might bring
some relief there are fears that rain
could trigger mudslides in the charred
areas
back in b.c the canadian forces
snowbirds have cancelled performances in
penticton abbotsford this week a day
after one of their planes went down
the aircraft was damaged in fort st john
on tuesday there are reports it stalled
shortly after takeoff before making a
rough landing the pilot was unhurt in a
statement the department of defense says
the downed plane won't fly again while
the air force investigates what exactly
went wrong
a giant in the legal profession and one
of canada's renowned criminal and civil
rights lawyers clayton ruby has died
ruby is being remembered as a persuasive
advocate for human rights on many
groundbreaking cases he defended former
mp sven robinson who was present for the
death of sue rodriguez long before the
laws that now protect medically assisted
dying in this country his high profile
cases included defending giphal moran
who was wrongfully convicted of murder
and he once defended a soldier dismissed
for her sexual orientation a policy that
was abandoned by the canadian military
before the case went to trial
clayton ruby who supported many cases in
pursuit of justice
dead at age 80.
russia's state-owned energy company
calls it impossible
coming up why it says it cannot accept
the delivery of a pipeline turbine fixed
in canada
russian energy giant gazprom now says
it's impossible to accept delivery of
the natural gas pipeline turbine that
had been repaired in canada now this
comes after the canadian government
exempted it from international sanctions
a move that was opposed by ukraine and
many canadians as redmond shannon
reports critics of ottawa's decision say
it was always clear that russia was
using energy as a weapon to manipulate
the west
german chancellor olaf schulz inspecting
the huge machine that's stuck in a
diplomatic limbo it is one of the
turbines used to pump natural gas from
russia to germany after it was sent from
russia to canada for maintenance ottawa
controversially issued an exemption to
sanctions to allow it to return via
germany
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
said canada's move would be seen by
moscow as a sign of weakness
says despite the technical and
contractual holdups being cited by
russia there is nothing stopping it from
onward delivery amid war in ukraine
russia has limited the pipeline to 20 of
capacity partly blaming the absent
turbine president zoensky said this was
precisely what was going to happen we
said this was precisely what was going
to happen
uh to some extent both the german and
the canadian government acknowledged
that this was going to happen and they
did it anyway
the ukrainian world congress even took
legal action to try and stop it
in montreal germany and canada's foreign
ministers said their joint strategy
proves vladimir putin's intentions ahead
of winter
we called his bluff
it is now clear that putin is
weaponizing energy flows to europe
the world sees through his game we have
shown as alliance that there's no chance
not angle a single inch that putin is
successful in splitting us just minutes
after the ministers spoke russia's
energy giant gasprom issued a statement
saying the delivery of the turbine is
impossible blaming sanctions
on thursday in ottawa the standing
committee on foreign affairs will
discuss the exemption which currently
could be applied to five more turbines
expect to hear testimony calling for it
to be rescinded redmond shannon global
news london
china is stepping up military drills as
u.s house speaker nancy pelosi wrapped
up her controversial visit to taiwan
chinese jets warships and missile crews
all participating in the drills a
saber-rattling response to pelosi's
visit some of those exercises taking
place within the 12 nautical mile zone
surrounding the island taiwan claims as
its territory during her visit pelosi
met with taiwan's president and members
of parliament and reaffirmed the us's
commitment to the status quo
our delegation came here
to send an unequivocal message
america stands with taiwan the united
states recognizes
the government of the people's republic
of china
as the sole legal government of china
while u.s and other western lawmakers
regularly visit taiwan pelosi is the
first house speaker to visit the island
since newt gingrich in 1997.
from hunters to researchers ahead the
widespread efforts to fight food
insecurity in iqaluit
if you thought food prices were sky high
in your hometown well try living in
canada's north
residents of icaluit are used to seeing
food prices two or three times higher
than the national average canada's
northernmost city is inaccessible by
road from the south and its short
growing season means food and supplies
often have to be flown in well now in
response to the inflationary crisis
inuit hunters are stepping up to provide
more food and they've just found a new
lifeline jeff semple reports from
iqaluit
the name acalaweed in inuktitut means
place of many fish and it's easy to see
why
grew up on these waters fishing for
arctic char as well as clams beluga
whales and seals and whatever they can't
eat themselves they share with friends
some of them don't have any hunters in
their family
some of them are elders we care a lot
i'm not the only one the other countries
do that but that long-standing inuit
tradition of sharing the catch has fast
become a lifeline for this remote
northern city
record high inflation has sent food
prices soaring across the country and
nowhere more so than canada's
northernmost communities ocala was
already home to some of the most
expensive food in the country and those
prices are climbing even higher this bag
of potatoes costs about 15
it's almost 22 dollars for a kilogram of
ground beef and a four liter jug of milk
will cost you more than eight dollars
that's two dollars more than the
national average
when it was a kid 10 cents for a pop
today you could
five dollars 25 cents for a problem
hunters like emilio alnaco and his
curious son jonah are now donating their
excess meat to this local food center
distributed daily to those in need
compared to last year demand for food
donations has doubled most of the food
we get is fluent in from south because
we don't have aquaculture it's too cold
up here in the north so we have to look
for other sources to that end this
inuit-owned development company recently
decided to look a little deeper
combining traditional knowledge with
cutting-edge technology they deployed
this new research vessel to map the
ocean floor
scouring the uncharted seabed in
nunavut's kicatani region looking for
new inshore fishing spots what we saw is
unbelievable from sea urchins and sea
cucumbers to scallops and shrimp to
clams and cod species that local
fishermen had seen for years in the
stomachs of whales and seals but never
knew where they came from
we were very pleasantly surprised even
though we knew a lot of the species were
there we certainly didn't visualize or
have any idea as to the quantity this
would add significantly to the diet of
the various communities their research
continues and these coordinates will be
shared with local communities so they
can be fished sustainably in hopes of
providing a new food source to meet the
growing need jeff semple global news at
caluit
pope francis dedicated his weekly
address at the vatican to his trip to
canada last week and again asked for
forgiveness for residential school
abuses
the phone slightly broadened the scope
of the apologies he delivered in
edmonton nunavut and quebec city saying
nuns priests and lay catholics
participated in programs of genocide and
assimilation that are now understood to
be unacceptable and contrary to the
gospel
the legacy of vin scully next the
baseball world bids farewell to a
broadcasting giant
it's rare to find someone widely
considered the best at their craft in
the baseball world sports commentator
vince scully was that person
he was a master of elegant phrasing
perfect timing but knew when to keep his
own air presence small while calling
some of the most memorable major league
games
he died tuesday at the age of 94. ross
lord looks at his legacy
[Applause]
every baseball fan knows the voice of
vin scully
[Applause]
but the qualities that made scully
universally admired go beyond the game
of baseball
qualities we wish for ourselves and our
children the elegance the style
the accuracy the literacy the fairness
that he brought to to broadcast scully
was born in the bronx the son of irish
immigrants his ambitions as a baseball
player were never realized he began
broadcasting in 1950 developing a style
that was measured and never rushed
much like the game itself
unlike many colleagues he resisted being
a partisan cheerleader not even for the
los angeles dodgers a team he called
thousands of games for over almost seven
decades of broadcasting if it was the
red sox yankees he didn't focus on the
yankees you know he gave both teams
involved an equal amount of uh of time
and i appreciated that because i
expected it was going to be the other
way around one ball
scully also had a keen sense of
baseball's place in society like in 1974
when henry aaron broke babe ruth's
all-time home run record what a
marvelous moment for the country in the
world
a black man is getting a standing
ovation in the deep south for breaking a
record of an all-time baseball idol
every broadcaster i've ever asked who's
the greatest baseball broadcaster of all
time they've said scully without
exception it was a big moment he'd let
the crowd reaction take over for his
voice
[Applause]
along with the presidential medal of
freedom scully was honored with an emmy
award and of course induction to the
baseball hall of fame scully's wife
sandra died last year he was a father of
five children and dozens of
grandchildren and great-grandchildren at
age 94 vin scully's elegant excellence
is unmatched ross lord global news
and that's global national for this
wednesday night i'm farah nasser and on
behalf of our whole crew i want to thank
you so much for spending part of your
evening with us tonight's york canada is
the inukshuk overlooking kluwani lake in
yukon
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and each other good night
[Music]
you